so the pandemic really changed
family life this year um jessica did did
you still get to do any family trips
over the summer did y'all do anything
we like yes we did
two road trips which we've never done
one
before this um i don't even think cash
and i
ever took a road trip prior to having
kids
yeah we've never done this one before
and
we sound like it went drove to wyoming
yeah we drove to wyoming uh
we stopped in zion it was 110 degrees
we were driving my brother's rv he did
let us borrow it it did not have air
conditioning it was
ten with no air conditioning sharing a
bed with our toddler who
has never slept outside of a crib before
um
and all my kids got very
vomitose carsick the entire time
and when we landed in zion at 11
p.m which would they they were like it's
two hours past
the time anyone is allowed to pull in
because it's lights out
this you know rv whatever and we're like
okay well anyways
we have nowhere else to go so we're just
gonna go here and
park the thing and cash backs in
and everyone's just like hot and they
want to get out
and we're starving we haven't eaten in
10 hours
and right when i take the baby out of
his car's seat he
vomits in my mouth and my eyes and
everyone in the rv goes
including cash and run out and so i'm
blinded
by warm acid vomit
and it's in my mind ah guys
guys and he's covered in it and
i my mom mind knows how to like
take off his clothes quickly because i
didn't want him like running around
the getting the vomit all over the rv
avi
and i like wanted to keep it contained
and
then this fool jumps out the rv
in his diaper and starts chasing frogs
like
nasty wild toads or frogs
and this is like our first time out of
our
house and sitting in four and a half
five months
and then he starts going to other
people's camps covet camps i'm like
the baby's gonna get cold and i'm like
still have the vomit everywhere i'm like
what is happening so this is like my our
first night that's a movie
that's the greatest scene from a movie
it was the
worst it was my nightmare it was my
actual nightmare
but then somehow three weeks later i'm
like let's do it again
and so we went up to bend oregon which
was
beautiful they have you know bicycles
and
it's very nice there but then we
accidentally
were driving and this time we did a
sprinter van
and we accidentally drove the kids into
a couple of the fires in napa by
accident
so that was that was that um
i mean i just feel like we lost cell
phone service
it was just it was a situation in my
situation so
yeah my kids might have ptsd from road
[Music]
trips
you